unas pocas docenas de personas se
reunieron en sebastopol para una
ceremonia en recuerdo del buque insignia
ruso moscú que se hundió el jueves la
mayor ciudad de crimea aleccionada por
rusia en 2014 era el puerto de origen
del barco de misiles fire
la pérdida de un barco especialmente un
buque insignia es una tragedia para
todas esas decenas de miles de personas
que sirvieron a bordo durante más de 20
años tanto oficiales como marineros
el crucero ruso construido durante la
época soviética estaba en servicio
activo desde
1986 participó en las últimas
intervenciones militares rusas en
georgia en 2008 en siria y en ucrania
más cuando aceptó en moscú para era un
símbolo para todo el mundo un símbolo de
poder esperanza y renacimiento de
nuestra flota en los años 90 era un
símbolo de nuestro éxito técnico y
científico
la causa del hundimiento sigue siendo
discutida
moscú lo achaca un incendio pero kiev
reivindica la responsabilidad de su
destrucción como resultado del
lanzamiento de misiles una versión
respaldada por el pentágono que afirma
que el moskvá fue alcanzado por dos
misiles neptune ucranianos y en contra
de las afirmaciones rusas que aseguran
que la tripulación podría haberse
salvado ucrania dice que la flota de 500
marineros a bordo de este barco no pudo
ser evacuada
el monstruo es el segundo buque de
guerra ruso destruido desde el inicio
del conflicto después de lorca en el
puerto de verde ans el 24 de marzo